[Music]
on this thursday night anger builds as a
protest rolls its way to ottawa from
opposing vaccine mandates i think they
pushed it a little too far to wanting to
overthrow the government and intimidate
the media you guys what's the point of
this and who is behind it thank you so
much tory introspection the report is
out on why the conservatives lost the
last federal election the family who
froze to death in manitoba identified we
believe this to be a case of human
smuggling the rcmp appeals for help from
the public plus a global news
investigation why is an ontario
telehealth company offering
prescriptions for ivermectin a drug not
approved for treating covid
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with that convoy heading to
ottawa
it rolled into the greater toronto area
today one of the demands is an end to
vaccine mandates for cross-border
truckers it is hard to know who is here
for that and who is angry about a whole
lot of other things there are people who
hate the prime minister and some who
want to overthrow the government and
there's lots of hostility towards the
media
it's also hard to know the exact numbers
hard to know too how many are actually
truckers there are lots of pickups and
other vehicles what is certain is that
the majority of truckers like the
majority of canadians are fully
vaccinated and they play a vital role in
keeping our shelves stocked and our
economy running tonight jeff semple
takes a deeper look at who is behind
this rolling protest
the so-called freedom convoy appears to
be gaining momentum
[Applause]
ontario police say around 400 vehicles
left thunder bay heading towards toronto
where many more were waiting to join the
procession to the nation's capital i'm
not a big fan of the mandates i think
they pushed it a little too far and i
think there's a lot of people here that
have the same message and i think it's a
positive one we're here on the north
edge of the city of toronto and take a
look at this there are hundreds of
people gathered here many of them with
canadian flags many of them carrying
signs condemning vaccine mandates and
prime minister justin trudeau
a lot of truckers of course but a lot of
ordinary vehicles as well a lot of
people here who aren't truckers aren't
related to the trucking industry at all
and a real sign that this movement has
become about much more than truckers and
vaccine mandates the protest appears to
have spiraled into a catch-all for
countless other issues it started with a
fairly specific concern about
covid related mandates and has expanded
out exponentially from that to you know
include far-right concerns around
globalization multiculturalism
anti-anti-government anti-trudeau
sentiment we are convoying right to
ottawa this sudbury man one of the
self-described organizers of the protest
appears to have previously encouraged
followers to loot grocery stores that
asked for proof of vaccination he's
listed politicians who were not born in
canada and said he planned to vandalize
a black lives matter mural for which he
later apologized this expert in
conspiracy theories says other members
have also called for the protest to
become canada's january 6th a reference
to the crowds that stormed the u.s
capitol last year i would like to see
our own january 6 event see some of
those truckers plow right through that
16 foot wall none of us of course i just
like to see it is this a peaceful
movement that's being hijacked by other
groups
well that's really hard to say everyone
does have the right to protest but there
are other actors who may be engaged who
see this as an opportunity for something
else the conservative finance critic
accused the media of focusing on a few
bad apples that doesn't mean we
disparage
the thousands of hard-working
law-abiding
and peaceful truckers
who quite frankly have kept all of you
alive the last two years by filling your
grocery shelves but ottawa police are
concerned enough that they're preparing
for a range of scenarios including the
potential for violence it's not just
your regular protest coming to the city
so
um people are concerned um i i will
await as we as we know more and see more
i i understand and in other areas we
have not seen violence but that was not
their target the target is ottawa
and jeff semple is with me now jeff you
spent the day out there with the
protesters what was the atmosphere like
it was a real mixed bag donna i have to
tell you there were a lot of truckers as
you saw there and their supporters who
were you know quite polite and positive
talking about the fact that they're
essential workers and feel that they're
being unfairly punished by the vaccine
mandate but there were also a lot of
other people and a lot of angry people
and a lot of that anger was directed at
us as journalists myself and my
colleagues here faced a lot of verbal
abuse all day and in fact one local news
crew called police here at one point
after they said that one of the
protesters tried to drive their cars
into one of the reporters while he was
doing his work so some very tense
moments today fueling fears that those
tensions may bubble over when that
convoy arrives to parliament hill
[Applause]
okay jeff semple in toronto tonight
thanks
ndp leader jagmeet singh says he doesn't
support the convoy and disagrees with
his own brother-in-law who donated 13
000 to it an ndp source tells global
news once jodhweer singh daliwal
understood the true nature of the
organization he asked for his money back
the ndp leader says i unequivocally
disagree with him about this donation
and told him so
well the conservatives lost the last
federal election and leader aaron
o'toole promised a post-mortem report to
pinpoint what happened it is now
complete and it was handed to tory mps
today our chief political correspondent
david aiken joins us now david aaron
o'toole also had lots to say today about
that protest convoy
yes and before we get to that donna some
breaking news the sergeant-at-arms in
charge of parliament hill security has
warned mps tonight in writing that those
protesters are looking for the home
addresses of parliamentarians now aaron
o'toole said just minutes ago he's going
to meet with these protesters here in
ottawa and he says if there's anger out
there he blames prime minister trudeau
i will always fight for the trucker
the essential worker the canadian who
wants to work
and so will any member
of the conservative caucus the question
is
why would prime minister trudeau not
stand up for working people
now about that post-mortem report on the
election the first thing to know is it
arrives in a period of controversy for
the conservative leader there is
significant dissatisfaction right now
within the party within his caucus about
his leadership some of his distractors
say this post-mortem report is a little
too easy on o'toole's failings now the
report has not been made public but
sources tell us there are dozens of
observations one of them the database of
the parties used for years for voter
identification and get out the vote
campaigns it's really badly broken
meanwhile the liberal database system
that does the same thing it's clicking
on all cylinders so conservatives say
that has to be fixed these database
systems are crucial parts of modern
campaigns but for critics of o'toole the
big problem with the election was what
those critics call his flip-flop he
campaigned for the leadership as a hard
right conservative vowing to kill the
carbon tax but in the general election
presented himself as a moderate who
would modify and keep the carbon tax and
the post mortem really did not address
that so this debate about o'toole's
leadership is happening and it is not
done yet donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thanks in
manitoba the rcmp has now identified the
family of four that froze to death in a
field near the u.s border police say
they arrived in toronto from india on
january 12 and made their way to emerson
manitoba on january 18th it's an
extended period of time for a family who
is unfamiliar with canada to be
traveling across the country
a part of the investigation is
determining whether this travel was
facilitated in some way by an individual
or individuals
this is the family 39 year old jagdish
patel and his 37 year old wife vaishali
12 year old vahinga and three-year-old
dharmic rcmp believed they were victims
of human smuggling they are asking
anyone who may have interacted with the
family to contact police and the police
in india have detained six people in an
illegal immigration crackdown they run a
travel and tourism company in the indian
state where the family is from
also a florida man is facing charges
prime minister justin trudeau is
isolating for five days after being
exposed to someone with covid19 he says
a recent rapid test was negative and he
feels fine we know the omicron variant
continues to drive the spread of covet
19 including in the places hardest hit
by the first wave long-term care homes
there are outbreaks right now at more
than 2 000 facilities across the country
the hardest hit provinces are quebec
ontario and alberta just over half the
people who died of covet in canada were
residents in long-term care and
retirement homes roughly 16 000 people
for years there have been calls to
implement national standards to help
improve care
now there is finally a blueprint abigail
beeman reports
when my mom went into long-term care as
for everyone we didn't know we were
giving up their rights jeanette harper's
mother didn't need a wheelchair when the
pandemic began she believes marguerite
bell might still be walking if she'd
been allowed regular visitors and
engagement for the last two years she
was just a vacant shell and you saw your
loved one just slipping away from you
through a window
harper says she's pleased to see this
draft set of national standards for
long-term care focused on resident
well-being with 181 criteria one of the
focuses respecting a resident's right to
live with risk a flashpoint in the
pandemic where prolonged isolation and
visitor restrictions have had
devastating consequences families are
just saying look we don't want to do
this we rather just get co-bid my mental
health cannot take another period of
lockdown i would have liked to have seen
very clear language on you are not
allowed
to separate family
again
period this long-term care advocate
wanted more specifics including a
minimum number of hours of care per
resident per day i was hoping to see
clear
standards that are actually enforceable
implementation is another matter ottawa
committed three billion dollars in the
last budget to improve long-term care
but wouldn't say thursday if it will
commit to legislating these national
standards the health and seniors
minister saying they will respect
provincial jurisdiction they are in a
way suggestions unless the government
takes the needed steps to both fund the
changes that these standards require
make staff available my god i'm hoping
that this will be a clear blueprint that
really can enable provincial and
territorial and federal action to move
long-term care to where all canadians
are demanding it to go these draft
standards focus on care there's a second
set in the works from another
organization which focus on infection
control and infrastructure after public
consultation both groups are expected to
present final versions by the end of the
year by then it will be nearly three
years since the horrors of the pandemic
in long-term care began
abigail beeman global news ottawa
ukraine planning its defense coming up a
look at what the country has in place in
case of a russian invasion
tensions remain high in europe tonight
the pentagon says the number of russian
forces near the ukrainian border has
increased in the last 24 hours the biden
administration says a russian invasion
of ukraine is imminent but war it says
can still be avoided still think there's
time and space for diplomacy i think
obviously that's that's the preferred
path here uh to de-escalate in a
peaceful calm way and destabilize uh
without any shots being fired
the kremlin has agreed to keep
diplomatic talks going but some military
analysts say russia is using the west's
desire for dialogue as a stalling tactic
our europe bureau chief crystal
gamansing reports
one after another fighter jets touched
down in belarus for war training a show
of strength from russia's military yet
their words are more measured
from our side says the russian foreign
ministry spokesperson we have repeatedly
stated that our country doesn't plan to
attack anyone the kremlin says it is
willing to keep the door open for
further talks despite the u.s rejecting
a key demand to bar ukraine from nato
there have been weeks of diplomatic
talks and so far they've been
unsuccessful russian military assets are
still lined up on ukraine's border
ukrainian security expert alina frolova
says russia is toying with the west
based on history we understand that
russia really takes any negotiable
position as the working position and
only the
super strength
reply
and some kind of aggressiveness towards
russia can stop it from from
aggression well ukrainians are getting
on with their daily lives the tension on
the border with russia is having an
impact the price of gas is going up and
the value of the dollar the local
currency the grief nut is being affected
yesterday on wednesday it would take you
28 krivna to buy one american dollar
today it's 29 that of course has a
knock-on effect with everything
including the price of basic supplies
such as food while there's been no
violent escalation there has been
movement ukraine is no longer only under
threat from the east but the north with
belarus where joint military exercises
are taking place with russia and from
moldova where the president of the
center for global studies says special
russian forces have been moved in mahalo
gunthar says since canada is not
supporting ukraine with weapons it could
provide naval support in the region
we need
more involvement
of
navies of uh non-black sea countries
which are members of the nato
for example from the united states
united kingdom and canada too to provide
more nato presence
in the black sea
it means
additional
deterring
of the
russia aggressiveness
russia is also conducting military
exercises in the black sea
high stakes dialogue will continue
friday when french president emanuel
macron will speak with vladimir putin by
phone macron has vowed to never give up
dialogue with russia
donna
crystal command singh in ukraine tonight
thanks
ahead the canadian company accused of
prescribing an unproven covid treatment
an ontario doctor barred from
prescribing ivermectin to treat covid19
has launched a telehealth service
offering the unapproved treatment a
global news investigation has uncovered
that he is exploiting a loophole and
experts say it shows the cracks in a
system that's supposed to protect
patients here's jamie morocco
this means that we can take our lives
back family dr patrick phillips medical
license has been restricted since the
fall as part of his suspension the
northern ontario physician isn't allowed
to prescribe ivermectin for covid but
global news has learned the doctor is
now a director of a new provincial
telehealth service canadian coveted
telehealth inc offering the
anti-parasitic drug it's not been
approved for use in covet 19 it's been
studied pretty extensively it's been
shown to be quite problematic and the
website services aren't cheap from 150
dollars for covid prevention to almost
400 for a complex coveted consultation
according to phillips lawyer he has
never issued a prescription for
ivermectin through the service when
asked about the telehealth network
prescribing the drug global news was
told the company does not control what
doctors give out while philip's
involvement and the existence of the
service isn't breaking any laws health
law expert timothy caulfield says it's a
loophole that needs to be closed it
creates confusion among the general
public and could do real harm if if
patients think that this is protecting
them or is the therapy that is actually
going to be effective after global news
reported on canadian doctors accused of
providing unproven covenant information
and in some cases falsifying masks and
vaccine exemptions last week ontario's
minister of health demanded the
province's college of physicians and
surgeons cracked down including
reviewing the licenses of physicians
found to be spreading misinformation of
more than 40 doctors the college is
investigating at least two are involved
in a group closely associated with the
telehealth service phillips is a
director of still the college says its
hands are tied when it comes to a
business it's incumbent on them
to
very specifically
advise
the ministry
of what legislative changes it needs
ontario's health ministry is giving the
college the green light telling global
it must investigate whether it's an
individual or business someone has got
to fix this
it erodes public trust in our health
care system during a health care
emergency concerned anything less puts
patients at risk jamie marrocker global
news toronto
next what the future holds as england
scraps coveted restrictions
our returning champion amy schneider has
now been with us 40 days and 40 nights
what a run after her historic winning
streak jeopardy champion amy schneider
has finally been beaten she finishes as
the highest winning woman on the show
and holds jeopardy's second longest
consecutive winning streak
just to really know that like
i'm you know one of the most successful
people at a game i've
loved since i was a kid wanted to be on
since i was a kid
and just to know that i'm i'm part of
its history now
i just i don't even know
how to process it
schneider admitted to the new york times
that after she left the set she briefly
cried in a bathroom but then collected
herself before heading out she's won
nearly 1.4 million dollars on the show
while many parts of canada are still
living under public health restrictions
england is ditching most of its rules
gone are mandatory face masks work from
home mandates even vaccine passports
there are fears it's too much too soon
as redmond shannon reports the world is
now watching what will happen to england
next
back to the office for many and no more
coveted passes or mask mandates for
millions
pandemic rules are all but scrapped in
england despite a falling case rate
that's still twice as high as canada and
a death rate averaging above 200 a day
so supermarkets and london's transit
system are asking people to continue to
wear face coverings on transport i'll
have to
it's for myself if it's in the subway it
might not be
very responsible i'd rather just make
people feel comfortable
by wearing one countries across europe
and around the world will be watching
england closely to see how the omicron
variant spreads with almost no
restrictions in place but other uk
nations like wales are keeping some
restrictions for now the real question
is is why is england such a global
outlier
in the way in which governments
elsewhere
are attempting to protect their
populations from coronavirus boris
johnson is a leader digging deep just to
keep his job facing multiple allegations
of rule breaking during lockdowns
honestly i i really couldn't speculate
as to why they've chosen right now it
doesn't seem to me to be based on the
data tara hearst is a uk-based canadian
virologist who says new testing rules
mean true infection rates are even
higher i think that is too soon i mean
looking at the case numbers they're
still quite high for any canadians
looking to sample england's new rules
soon no tests will be needed for fully
vaccinated flyers to the uk redmond
shannon global news london
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is the plains near kioma
alberta beautiful shot thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]